what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel mcu
and of course spider-man no way home and
today we have some details about the
film
and some very very interesting leaks
these are somewhat unique to what we've
heard recently
and if one of these in particular
happens to be true it kind of explains
what
sony pictures universe of marvel
characters is actually doing
with venom and morbius and why the daily
bugle is the exact same daily bugle from
the sam raimi spider-man universe and
there is just a whole
dump of leaks on the internet right now
from people claiming to have
auditioned for the movie therefore know
a little bit about a certain scene
others claiming that they know somebody
close to marvel studios or
sony and they heard a little bit about
the film and if one of these ends up
being true we also know a little bit
more about the relationship between sony
and
marvel and the control that marvel has
over spider-man
which is always a great thing because
marvel knows what they're doing so there
is a ton to dive into today but before
we get started be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
videos
so we'll start off by a pretty decent
credible source
the twitter account superhero theorist
seems to know a lot of the plot
of spider-man no way home at least
that's what this person is claiming
this person is of murphy's
multiverse.com and they have a pretty
good reputation
with the scoops and the leaks that they
do put out there into the public and
based off of some of their recent tweets
we learn a little bit about the film
one of them is another confirmation of
the main
villain of the film and the account that
originally tweets this the marvel
sheriff makes a pretty good point he
says
willem dafoe's norman osborne is in this
movie i'm having a hard time believing
daniel rpk
charles murphy the illuminati collider
and casey walsh all collectively got
false information about him being in the
movie
there's no denying it at this point he's
as good as confirmed in my book
and then charles murphy of murphy's
multiverse quote tweeted it saying he is
now i start by this and mention it
because this
is actually a very valid point all of
these scoopers mentioned
have been right about many different
scoops in the past even if they're not
100 correct on
everything they've put out nobody really
is but these people do have decent track
records and collider is a
huge trade company they always interview
people like
marvel studios president kevin feige all
of the actors for whatever movie or show
was coming up so they have a pretty good
relationship with marvel studios disney
etc etc
them combined with these other scoopers
who have good track records i would also
say that it's pretty much confirmed that
william defoe's norman osborne is indeed
going to be the main villain of this
film but then we get a comment about the
multiverse one person tweeted the fact
that we are going to see these two
finally interact gets me so hyped
talking about willem the foes green
goblin slash norman osborne and doc ock
in which superhero theorists replied the
film really is
a love letter to spider-man fans
specifically
to raymie and the amazing spider-man
fans somebody else went on to ask would
you say it's more of a love letter to
those spider-man
or all of them including tom's
spider-man
in which they replied i mean everyone
really but maybe raimi
and the amazing spider-man fans will
have the most fun with it
now to me this is really great news
because it tells me two things
one is that toby maguire spider-man from
the sam raimi universe and
andrew garfield spider-man from the
amazing spider-man universe aren't just
going to be
quick little five-minute six-minute
seven whatever minute cameos they're not
just going to pop up on the screen for a
second
in one of dr strange's portals and then
go away although i'm sure fans would
still be pretty excited about that even
just to see them in the movie but it
seems like these characters and the
characters from their universes
are actually going to be pretty involved
another thing that this tells me is that
the leaks that we've been hearing about
the sinister six forming of villains
from other universes
is most likely true as well and it
really sounds like it's going to be just
an
awesome combination of all three
different spider-man universes now these
are pretty much
details out there about the movie but
like i mentioned in the beginning we do
have some leaks and they are pretty
interesting
the first one is about spider-man no way
home venom
and morbius essentially the sp umc and
how it connects to the mcu spider-man
this leak states that the venom and
morbius movies are actually an
alternate version of the sam raimi
spider-man movies
this explains why the daily bugle logo
is exactly the same as in the raimi
movies
in this universe spider-man 3 hasn't
happened yet
spider-man hasn't met venom or eddie
brock another difference
is that in this universe norman osborne
never died and what exactly happened to
him after the fight with spider-man
i have no idea this is just what i was
told as for dog och
it's pretty much what alfred molina said
that his character's story picked up
right after he fell into the water
now this is a very very interesting
thought
and i would actually really commend sony
if this is truly what they're doing this
kind of takes a lot of planning in
advance however they have been working
with marvel studios for a while now
ever since civil war so it really
wouldn't surprise me at all if sony and
marvel and disney were all working
together to create this
huge universe or kind of two different
universes
because they definitely thrive off of
the success of one another sony thrives
more off of the success of
marvel obviously but it's really
beneficial to marvel if
sony films like venom and venom let
there be carnage and morbius do
well and connect and we have seen the
original daily bugle logo
in venom let there be carnage and we've
even seen it in some leaked photos for
morbius
so there is clearly a connection here
especially when you consider we have the
same
jjjonah jamison in spider-man far from
home in the end credits and he's going
to be in spider-man no way home this
could be yet
another alternate version so to me this
makes
a lot of sense and even though i did
personally enjoy spider-man 3 i know
there are a lot of people out there who
didn't and would rather have that movie
kind of erased also i'd like to point
out that if this leak is true
harry osborn is still alive and has not
died because they said spider-man 3 has
not happened yet and i would personally
love for a
james franco cameo in spider-man no way
home but i'm not getting my hopes up
this next leak comes from somebody who
claims to have auditioned for a role in
spider-man no way home and didn't get it
but one of his friends
did and that role was the role of a
juror this leak says i tried out for the
jury in no way home
didn't get the part but his best friend
persisted and was cast as a juror and
saw
a certain blind man representing tom as
well as
separate shots mentioning she-hulk in
case dd
rights as in daredevil weren't cleared
but it seems daredevil scenes will be
used without a doubt
didn't see a costume but he was a dang
good lawyer now this kind of lines up
with what we've heard before and it's
kind of the same situation as
norman osborn enough trade companies
have reported that matt murdock is going
to be in the movie
that i'm really expecting it at this
point it's not confirmed by any means
but it just seems to make sense and
would be really really cool to see he's
a lawyer in new york he's a superhero on
the side but they don't reveal that he's
a superhero but it would make sense that
he would want to defend
another superhero and literally every
report that we have
states that it's not daredevil showing
up but matt murdock he's not going to be
donning his costume he's simply going to
be a lawyer
now this next leak is very interesting
because it talks about the relationship
between sony and marvel studios and of
course we always want to know what's
going on with these guys
and what's posted actually seems pretty
legitimate this person claims that
they're an affiliation
in some way with a toy manufacturer so
working for a big toy company
and this person says so basically i've
been hearing rumors that marvel has more
control over the spider-man no way home
film
and i can in fact confirm that usually
for the previous films me and my boss
would have
around a three-hour meeting with one of
the guys over at sony but this time we
had the meeting with sony the same guy
who came for the far from home meeting
back in early 2019
and a guy from marvel this time they
ordered like four sets for the film and
another set for the new spider-man ride
opening up at disneyland
they were very secretive about this film
and my colleague who helped design the
in-game sets thinks they probably gave
us fake things to make sets off of like
they did with in-game
so this is a very specific leak that i
don't think a lot of people
would sit there and make up or even come
up with and if it's true that's
incredibly good news for us that means
marvel studios and disney has
a lot of control over spider-man no way
home
and spider-man moving forward now this
last leak that i'm about to mention i'm
gonna go ahead and put a disclaimer out
stating that i don't believe it but it
is rather interesting to think about so
i thought why not just put the thought
out there
now in case for some random reason this
is true i'm not going to go too much
into detail but it basically states that
loki is going to be playing a pretty
decent part and spider-man no way home
this is because of the events that
happen in the loki series
obviously time travel is involved and
some type of alternate timelines in the
multiverse is involved in loki and who
knows how it's going to end and the
events probably are going to lead into
spider-man no way home however i just
don't think loki's going to be in the
movie that is just too much at that
point
but then again there's so much in it why
not just throw one more thing in there
and after all dr strange did say in thor
ragnarok that he was monitoring loki
and they have met so maybe there are
definitely plenty of ways to make this
work and it could actually make sense
but to me it's just so much in one movie
that i'm really not counting on this
but like i said we had a lot of
spider-man knowing home news and
leaks today so be sure to let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof